what a mess and you know it's not just a
soap opera at the top of the Tory party
they've done huge damage to our economy
huge damage to our reputation as a
country and what we can't have now
because the public are paying the price
for this mortgages Etc what we can't
have as a revolving door of chaos the
next experiment for leader of the Tory
party and prime minister we have an
alternative that's a stable labor
government and the public are entitled
to have a say on this we need a general
election okay so can you'll call in for
a general election but at a moment of
acute instability there has been Market
instability there's a cost of living
crisis the Tories are going to replace
the Prime Minister within a week
in the general election is going to take
weeks and weeks and weeks can you see
that that I'm not I'm not kind of asking
you to comment on the principle of it of
legitimacy no but can you see that that
might not be practical right now but the
risk to the country is carrying on with
this utter chaos
um so you've got this real Choice utter
chaos with the conservatives or
stability under a labor government so
the risk is not a general election the
risk is carrying on with this utter
chaos they've made huge they've damaged
the economy very badly in the last few
weeks this damage has been done people
watching this program will be paying
more on their mortgages as a result of
the experiment that Liz trust imposed on
this country but we've had 12 years of
this so I don't accept the argument that
the general election is a risk not at
all because an incoming labor government
that can stabilize the economy and has
got a plan for growth that is credible
and will drive up working conditions and
standards and deal with the cost of
living crisis is what this comes just
finally though on this and then we'll
move on might it not be better to have a
general election in the spring once we
have got through winter once the
economic plan has been laid out because
a general election and potential
complete change of leadership in terms
of governing party it might spook the
markets more and the risk of spooking
the markets more is there is a material
effect as you know on people's food
bills on their mortgages on their their
livelihoods and it might be more
responsible of you to say I want a
general election but I want to get
through this immediate cost of living
crisis is that not a fair argument if
you look at the last few weeks the only
thing that spooked the markets is that
Kamikaze mini budget that's what spooked
now they're fixing it because they're
going to get rid of the person I think
many people are saying really you burn
through three prime ministers and you
want another go you've burnt through
four chancellors and you want another go
you've had 12 years of failure you've
inflicted economic damage and around the
world our reputation has been affected
and you want to just carry on you want
to pretend that that's the route to
stability see it isn't and I've had
people coming up to me you've probably
had it saying what is going on this is a
mess I'm embarrassed we need change are
you angry I'm not angry on my part I'm
really angry for people who'll be
watching this who are going to be paying
more if you're paying as a result of
what this government has done to our
economy three four five hundred pounds
more on your mortgage because it's not
on a fixed mortgage that is every month
you are paying you're not getting
anything more you're not getting a
better house you're not getting some
luxury holiday you're getting the same
thing you're paying more because this
government carried out an experiment on
the country and I think it's time to say
enough is enough we need to move on from
this we don't have to do it this way
there is an alternative a stable labor
government with real leadership with a
real plan for an economy that works for
working people I think it's time to put
that choice to the country do you want
to carry on with this utter chaos or do
you want stability under a labor
government it's okay you went up against
Liz trust you've only had to do it three
times yeah
um next week will be her fourth and
final prime minister's questions it's
barely believable even saying that such
shorter tenure do you feel sorry for her
well look I can see that there's
um pressure on intense pressure on her
and
um I think we can all see that that
takes its toll and I don't as a human
being you know want to see that in
anyone but I think it is important for
me to say that for millions of people
who are really struggling to pay their
bills to make ends meet to meet their
mortgage payments going to food banks
they're under a huge strain as well and
we need to take that into account and we
need to allow them to say do you want to
carry on with this or do you want to
change you want a general election you
accept though you're not going to get
one well you're not getting one yeah as
much as you want you're not getting one
if we don't get one it'll be for one
reason and one reason only and that is
that conservative MPS who know very well
this is unsustainable we'll put their
party first and not the country first
and I believe all politicians should put
the country first it was my main message
to my party at our conference in
September so I say to those Tory MPS put
your country first not your party first
but you do accept that you're asking for
something you won't get you you would
acknowledge that yeah well let's see
where we get to this is unprecedented
we've not burnt through Prime Ministers
and chancellors and home secretaries
like this ever in our history so I think
it is time to say we are in an
unprecedented World here we can't carry
on like this this is real damage being
done to our economy to our reputation we
need to stop this chaos and move on you
want to stop the chaos but the chances
of an election I think are quite bluntly
that'll be up to Tori MPS and it's like
turkey's voting for Christmas right
if they decide that their party comes
first and their country comes second uh
then that's a matter for them but I have
to say I think that's the wrong way I'm
just saying they might think that they
have a new more effective leader and
that does put the country first at this
moment in time you you get that you
might agree but you understand that
argument they spent the summer tearing
each other apart there are vicious
arguments going on inside the
conservative party it's two parties
Under One Roof there was a bloodletting
over the summer we've now had a few
weeks of this experiment with Liz truss
which is cost people hugely in terms of
their finances
um and I think that you know the idea
that they can suddenly come together in
happy Harmony and provide stability is
simply not realistic there are reports
um that Boris Johnson is considering
another run at office it is going to be
put to party members in some form
what do you think of that the return of
Boris Johnson I remind myself that I
think it was just about three months ago
his own party said that he was unfit for
office that's why he resigned his own
front bench were resigning on mass not
because they disagreed with him on some
policy issue but because they had
concluded that he was unfit for office
so if the argument or the proposition
from the conservative party is okay we
may have had you know a few weeks of
economic chaos done huge damage to the
economy so what we now want to do is can
we go back to a man that only three
months ago we all said was unfit for
public office I think most people would
say I'll probably say knocking on the
door look before you start down this
road uh I think I should have a say and
I think we should have the choice
between that option or a labor
government under Kia stalma to provide
the stability this country needs you
think the idea of Boris Johnson return
is like a bad joke going back to a man
that I thought he was unfit for office
but his own party his own MPS remember
they were resigning on mass because
because they decided he was unfit for
office so to go from this Kamikaze
experiment that has cost the public
dearly under Liz truss back to a man who
his own party thinks is unfit for office
is is the most powerful case for a
general election you could ever have
and just finally there are a number of
other potential Runners and Riders
there's Rishi sanak
there's Penny Morden there's Ben Wallace
when you look at the would-be next prime
minister because because it's not going
to be you
um is there anyone that you think I
could do business with that person or
that's a reasonable Choice well I don't
fixate on the individual because in the
end it's a battle of ideas we have our
clear plan for the economy I've got a
clear plan about how we put in place a
sustainable program for improving living
standards dealing with the cost of
living the next generation of jobs I'm
confident in Labor's plans I'm confident
what the labor party has to offer I'm
confident labor party has the answers to
the challenges facing the country so in
terms of who is next up pause the next
experiment for the Tory party
um that doesn't matter much to me
because in the end it's a battle of
ideas and we have the ideas finally in
terms of what's happened this week we've
seen a governing party imploding
um
you clearly don't take pleasure in that
but politically this is to your
advantage
they've been imploding I think for years
but it's good for you isn't it well it's
not good for the country because this
implosion this fighting this division
this chaos is costing people in their
pockets and working people going out
working really hard paying now higher
prices paying higher mortgages they're
paying the price for this so it doesn't
give me any pleasure to see them implode
like this it does make me absolutely
convinced that we need to say enough of
this we've had 12 years of this we've
got absolutely nothing to show for it
let's have the fresh start that Britain
needs and so here just one more thing
when we spoke at Labor conference you
said to me you always believed you could
win in one term and that you would
eventually become Prime Minister after
the events the past 48 hours are you now
more confident of that statement I was
always confident that we could change
the labor party
expose the government has not fit to
govern and then go forward into
government I do think and believe that
we can win that general election that's
why I've put my whole team
yes I think that I hope in a labor
victory has turned very much into a
belief in a labor government